Salut YouTube ! C'est la 183e vidéo ce qui veut dire que je suis à la moitié de mon défi
puisque cette année 2016 j'avais décidé de faire une vidéo par jour du 1er janvier au 31 décembre !
dans cette vidéo j'ai une grosse surprise pour vous mais déjà j'aimerais vous remercier d'être là depuis le début
ou depuis pas très longtemps
merci également à tous les Youtubeurs et les Youtubeuses qui m'ont invités sur leurs chaînes
Et ce qui fait plaisir c'est que pour fêter la moitié du défi les acteurs du YouTube Game m'ont envoyé un message vidéo
j'ai reçu pleins de messages aujourd'hui et je vais les découvrir en même temps que vous.
Et pour fêter ce jour spécial j'ai 3 annonces à faire aux abonnés je vous le dit à la fin de la vidéo
on se retrouve après
joyeux mi-défi la team Mentalo !
*vidéos de personnes souhaitant des félicitations à Fabien*
Fabien Olicard ? Ouais sympa comme mec
Sympa mais un peu énervant. Si si
Oh et puis son truc là, POUCE EN L'AIR ! ouais ça va; c'est insupportable
insupportable
Ouais je sais fallait dire un truc sympa mais bon...
Comme ça tu pourras screener sur ce que tu veux
Yeah !
*rire*
visage de la peur !
Coucou les filles c'est Boobs de Boobs and a gang , juste un petit message pour dire que j'adore la chaîne de Fabien Olicard
je pense que c'est vraiment une chaîne géniale
c'est un mentaliste il nous apprend pleins de trucs
que c'est vraiment trop bien
et moi ça m'intrigue vachement je pense que
quoi ?
tu penses au 16
oui
et ensuite 16 nuancés de ta nouvelle palette de fard à paupières
bah ouais il est mentaliste
Moi je peux le faire Fabien Boulicar là
Olicard
Olic...
allez hop tu dors
Écoute si j’étais tout à fait honnête avec toi
je dirais que tu as l'air un petit peu fatigué quand même
t'as pas besoin de vacances toi
parce que l'année bissextile fallait le faire quand même
Une vidéo par jour pendant 1 an !!
Non, mais c'est pas possible
qui peut faire ça !
j'ai compris ! non mais ça y est. le mec est mentaliste. Forcément il nous a tous embrouillé l'esprit
c'est la même vidéo qui passe tous les jours !!
et nous on y voit que du feu
on a l'impression que c'est une nouvelle vidéo à chaque fois
hé beh oui bah voilà !!
forcément non mais attends ! pff ! une vidéo par jour non mais c'est ça !
je suis un poulet
*imitation de la poule*
je vais en remettre une petite couche aujourd'hui vite fait
pour se déguiser en Fabien Olicard comme ça on pourras faire les vidéos à ta place quand on trouveras un truc
donc pour ça c'est pas compliqué : papier, crayon, rhodoïd, feutre
et voilà on a fait le feutre sur rhodoïd
maintenant on vient se placer comme il faut
hop on se place comme ça
et voilà maintenant on peut faire du Fabien Olicard sur YouTube
il y a 183 jours Fabien Olicard est venu me parler de
d'un concept qu’il voulait mettre en place : une vidéo par jour pendant 1 an
honnêtement
bah ouais
j'avais très envie d'y croire
mais *rire* je me suis dit que pendant 1 an
c'est vraiment chaud
et cet enfoiré il est à 6 mois de vidéo
Bravo Fabien je t'embrasse
*son de la tv*
Déjà laisse moi analyser la vidéo
qu'est ce que je t'ai dit !?
tu suis tout ce qu'il à dit Fabien Olicard !
c'est qui les winners !?
c'est qui qui va mettre Fabien Olicard à l'amende hein !?
c'est qui ?!
il faut que tu regardes toutes ces vidéos ! tu apprends tout !
c'est qui le prochain mentaliste !?
c'est moi !
qui c'est qui va gagner Fabien Olicard ?!
qui c'est qui vous mentalise !?
C'EST MOIIII !!!
et surtout n'oublies pas de mettre un petit
POUCE EN L'AIR !!
salut Fabien Olicard
salut les fans de Fabien Olicard
on m'a obligé à participer
donc je suis très content
voilà
bon
bah écoutes continue mon grand !!
bon courage !
c'est moi qui vais te mentaliser et qui vais vous mentaliser
vous qui regardez cette vidéo
je vais forcer votre esprit à penser à un mot précis
et uniquement en vous jouant quelques notes de guitare
c'est parti
*guitare*
et là si vous pensez
vous avez le droit de mettre un pouce
en l'air !
non mais franchement Fabien
j'ai pas bien suivi tes cours de mentalisation ?
allez !
c'est bon j'ai ce qu'il faut là
t'as mon papier d'alu ?
j'ai du papier sulfu
mais tu sais bien qu'il y a que le papier d'alu qui marche !
non mais Jeanne
tu vas t'en mettre ! met ta tête dans le four en attendant
je te rappelles que protéger sa tête avec du papier d'aluminium est le seul rempart fiable pour protéger ses pensées de Fabien Olicard
ouais mais ça c'e'st du papier sulfu
même
c'est bon
écoute il revient que dans 3 heures
t'as le temps
je sens les ondes elles sont là Si si !
et bah félicitations Fabien, félicitions d'avoir réussi à berner tout le monde pendant une demi-année
mais je croyais que tu l'aimais bien Fabien
oh oui je l'aime bien, je vais pas l'oublier
je peux fermer le four ou ?
c'est bon tu peux y aller
les gars !  Lamine Lezghad
petite vidéo de tournée je suis dans une ville c'est un petit peu galère
on s'emmerde un peu c'est une ville où il se passe pas grand chose
donc j'en profite pour te faire une petite vidéo
tu vois un petit peu ce qui se passe
je t'embrasse à bientôt ma poule bises
captain ! chuut ! arrête d'aboyer s'il te plait
il m'a dit : "je veux absolument que toi tu fasses un passage"
le voyage à Tahiti qu'il me doit ?
je laisse, je laisse filer il va bien s'en souvenir un jour qu'il me le doit ce voyage à Tahiti
donc s'il te plaît chut
allez c'est parti
allez
eeet salut !
voilà hyper fier de mon pote Fabien Olicard
183 vidéos déjà
ah vraiment.. faut vraiment euh..
avoir rien à foutre de sa vie
ouais
et sa profite des aides sociales ! ah bravo
elle est belle la France
une vidéo par jour ! tu sais j'ai été le 1er à être au courant
ça devait être au mois de décembre quand il a balancé ce truc un peu taré
et puis attends il a fait 6 mais c'est le bout du monde je pense que
moi je lui donne jusqu'au mois d’août
franchement il passe pas l'été
POUCE EN L'AIR
mais quelle vidéo pleine de sympathie je me demande ce que je vais recevoir le 31 décembre
à la fin du défi
alors déjà je n’arrêterais pas les vidéos
je continue l'année prochaine
sous une autre forme on aura le temps d'en parler dans l'autre partie de l'année
je me suis lancé un grand défi pour les 50 000 abonnés je ne pensais pas qu'on approcherait aussi vite c'est génial
si vous voulez en savoir plus allez voir la vidéo numéro 100 j'explique tout dedans
la semaine prochaine je vais également lancer un jeu sur la chaîne pour mentaliser l'un ou l'une d'entre vous
mentalisation d'abonnés ! comme j'avais déjà fait ici
et surtout recevoir toutes ces vidéos ça m'a donné une idée
si vous voulez m'envoyer une vidéo, vous me faites une vidéo
juste pour thème la moitié du défi
ça peut être quelque chose de gentil, ça peut être quelque chose d'ironique, ça peut être une moquerie, ça peut être complètement décalé, ça peut être complètement hors sujet
vous prenez votre téléphone et vous la mettez sur instagram, sur facebook, ou sur twitter
en tout cas à chaque fois taguez moi bien dedans vous avez touuus mes réseaux dans le descriptif
si vous le faites sur facebook taguez bien la fanpage
et toute la semaine prochaine je vais relayer les vidéos que j'aurais trouvé le plus sympa ou le plus drôle ou les coups de coeur
je sais que bien souvent vous êtes surprenant j'ai hâte de voir tout ça
on attaque la 2nd partie de l'année cet été il va y avoir des choses
mais je suis en train de caler pleins de changements, pleins d'évolution à partir de septembre
j'ai hâte de vous parler de tout ça merci à vous tous de la team Mentalo d'être là
n'hésitez pas à me dire dans les commentaires ce que vous aimeriez voir dans la prochaine vidéo
si vous voulez me souhaiter un très joyeux moitié défi vous pouvez faire exploser littéralement le compteur des pouces en l'air
abonnez vous si c'est pas déjà fait vous pouvez également abonner vos amis puisque le mentalvlog
c'est une vidéo par jour pendant 1 an et c’était la moitié rendez vous demain a 17h ciao !